What advice would you give to your 16-year-old self?
When someone challenges you or a group,
sometimes know when not to take the challenge on,
like I'm going to lose, that's going to suck,
but sometimes know when to take the challenge on.
In my freshman year in college,
a professor said, "If no one takes the final exam,
everyone will get an A.
But if one person takes it,
everyone in the class will get a double F, get a zero,
and the whole class will fail."
And for ten years, he had been doing this challenge.
And this was most popular class in college,
and there were students of all years,
two valedictorians from their respective classes were in there.
And as a freshman, I didn't know any better.
I just said, "Alright, I'm going to organize this,"
and I helped everyone not to take the exam.
We all got A's,
and then I became infamous for organizing this.
And so, a part of the reason why I'm an organizer
at the media lab,
in the domain of education,
was probably because of that experience.
So, what I would say to myself
or any 16-year-old,
that if someone challenges you,
know when to take it on
and take it on big.
And if you win and it's epic,
that becomes part of who you are,
part of how people see you,
and part of how you approach doing future things.
Click any of these fortune cookies
to see your questions and follow-up questions explored.
Click this cookie to return to the intro video
and see what this series is all about,
or click this cookie to suggest
alternative questions,
participants,
or career paths
for future videos.